bytes and molecules every living cell
has its own hard drive where it stores
bytes of information needed to function
and grow adapt to environmental changes
and fight off dangerous intruders this
information is stored in molecules that
are arranged in sequences of letters
referred to as DNA code in the 1990s a
tremendous effort by governments
researchers and companies resulted in
the full sequence of the human genome
since then we've seen an exponential
growth of molecular data that describes
cells tissue organs and organisms
massive datasets containing genetic
information about the young old healthy
and sick are now freely available to the
public here we will explore the various
omics data types as well as examples of
the information they contain in genomic
variants associated with ancestry gene
expression levels responsible for cancer
spread and protein modifications that
can render important code unreadable
this course is intended for all those
interested in understanding how the
current revolution in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health
[Music]
bytes and molecules